花に見切りが出来ました
始めシャツをで見てわかると思うんですけど僕ん家の床はなんか
フローリングを痛めたじゃないからこういうちょっと柔らかめの白黒のなんか今
ちょっと食べたらないんですけどこれ何で以上もカバーしてますけど
もう夏ですよなつなつなんですけど僕は外に出る気がありません
系の僕はなぜが好きなんてこうやっぱりね
夏お味られているわけですよけど僕は引きこもり
この矛盾をね解決するために今日
この部屋の床を全部人工芝にしようと思います人工芝にすれば僕は a でねこうね
家で光栄で音記号を持っている時も
床を見れば床はもう完全に真夏ですよ
2サマーカーニバルですよネッコロであればもうね一瞬でピクニック気分になれるんだ
ね毎日ね
サンドイッチともうベッドを持ってね寝ようと思いますみなさん部屋でもできると思う
ので是非ね今回はちょっとしっかりやっていこうと思いますではいかん
マザーですねその部屋のだいたいの間取りを絵に書いておきます本当に的飛び
はっきり分かればいいですこんな感じです
ね酷寒はメジャーので正確な部屋の大きさを測っていきます
北米
レーザー好きなんですよね音痴は測ってそれはさっきの神にはっきり記入してしまう
で上がっていこう56 s pen p ななんと4000 s なぜ56点1042
ごめんスプーンでとレイバー245ページです
ok ですシェアの大きさが分かりましたヘアのサイドのわかったので
ただ地方
フェンダーとかにせて人工芝売ってるってこれ知事鋭いすごい計算しないといけないか
だいたいな感じで行かせていただきますでは開発に行ってきますよ
こうやって入ったわけで千葉を買って来ましたあそこさを良い子はわかったんで
メガネ結構ねぇいいんですよ市立鎌
ステッチクズ後ろブザーつで結構音目てもいいよみたいな
ちょっと子とリアセミするてこの何か語りかけてくれるよ調べなんで
安心して使えます早速ね部屋に弾いていこうと思います
朝
あさみっ
長澤ハサミが入りますね
トップ
さあガッツリらが追加暑いですねジャーキーで行
ハサミあたりハサミを一瞬出なかった
b
こういうちょっと出っ張ってるもっとだったらハサミでも切って調整しちゃいましょう
いっ
おおーー
then
me
ええええええ
デーラー
me
voodoo
いいねんえお食事車ってどこでしたぜひ皆さんねあのボケこれ多分実家に行ったら親に
ぶっ殺されるんですけど
まあ一人暮らしだからできるということがなるってねまあ実家でする人は殺さない程度
に頑張ってみてください
pm 2
入って夕食
どんどん部屋の使用も変えていこうと思っていますこの層は理由
ぜひ家にでちょっとバイもみたいな人が山に遊びにしてやっぱり4人いるとなると
やっぱスバル場所がないんだよねちょっと合っちゃっ
たソファーなんですけどこう
偉そうに動画を取ろうと思いますやっぱり r ハウルとネバー空気も変わるんでね
ぜひ皆さんも部屋に芝生を
今度からこの側で動画をだろうとん
と思います
じゃ